Musik Hallo liebe Leute, herzlich willkommen zum Podcast mit Folge 5. Die magische Folge 5. Haben wir nicht mal gesagt, dass wir bis zu Folge 5 warten und dann uns ein Konzept überlegen oder sowas? Nee, wir haben gesagt, dass wir die ersten beiden Folgen zu einer Staffel zusammenfassen, danach schon die zweite beginnt. Also sind wir eigentlich schon bei der dritten Staffel jetzt. Wir sind schon in Staffel 3 und wir haben auch glaube ich gesagt, ab Folge fünf fangen wir an Gäste einzuladen. Ja genau. Ihr dürft euch also freuen. Wer ist heute zu Gast? Wir machen mal ein bisschen lauter, Freunde hier, sondern man hört mich ja kaum so jetzt. Richtig, zu Gast ist Nicolas Cage. Hallo. Hallo. Ja, er hat was an der Stimme, deswegen sagt er aber nicht so viel. Naja, apropos Stimme, ich finde, du hast halt eine fantastische, tiefe Stimme. Was ist los mit dir? Das hast du los mit dir gesagt im vorgespräch ich versuche dich immer ein bisschen vor der aufnahme zu motivieren dein selbstbewusstsein ein bisschen hoch zu treiben damit du dich wie bei den letzten drei folgen immer rumheulst also mit einer guten laune reingehst ja ich bin auch wahnsinnig gut klaunt ich bin einfach nur krank deswegen habe ich so eine schöne stimme aber hast du heute schon deine ganzen mailbox ansagen aufgenommen ja genau ich habe Da wurde gesagt sowas wie, ja, hallo, hier ist George Clooney, Servant Heats, herzlich willkommen auf meiner Mailbox. Also ich begrüsse die Leute auf meiner Mailbox, herzlich willkommen auf meiner Mailbox. Aber du bist bestimmt so jemand, der lässt sich auch mal zu einem Gag hin auf der Mailbox, oder? Da gibt es auch einen kleinen Gag. Nee, ich habe ehrlich gesagt noch niemals eine Ansage selber gemacht. Ich habe immer diese nette Telekom-Frau, die einem die ganze Nummer noch mal vorsagt, die man eben angerufen hat. Als ob man nicht wüsste, wem man gerade angerufen hat. Ja, aber die Nummer hilft dir auch nicht. Überhaupt nicht. Sie haben angerufen, 0,1, und wir weisen nicht, wen ich angerufen habe, ich kenne die Nummer halt nicht. Das ist doch aus einer alten Zeit, ein Relikt aus einer alten Zeit. Ja? Erzähl mir mehr davon. Ja, als man sich die Nummer noch auswendig lernen musste. Mein Gott, lass mich doch mal ein bisschen in meinem Loop-Mockridge-Modus sein.
Wir sind jetzt Hauptprogramm, wir müssen jetzt ein bisschen mehr in Richtung Loop-Mockridge denken.
Wir brauchen einfache Gags, die man einfach versteht, wo jeder was mit anfangen kann.
Ich finde, ehrlich mal, also man muss uns mal loben,
heute haben wir wahnsinnig gute technische Voraussetzungen,
wir klingen wahrscheinlich wieder besser als letzte Woche, wo ja nichts funktioniert hat.
Technisch waren wir sowas von irgendwie in einer Steinzeit, wir hatten kein Internet. Ja, vor allem, Mir ist beim Schnitt aufgefallen, dass auch die Differenz zwischen dir und mir nicht immer gleich war. Manchmal war eine Sekunde zwischen uns und manchmal zwei Sekunden. Es war sehr schlecht und dadurch wirkst du an manchen Stellen sehr träge. Und ich sage was, dann dauert das und dann sagst du was. Und tatsächlich, ich kann das auch nicht anders machen. Leider bist immer du der Dumme am Ende, der immer ewig wartet. Da kann ich auch nichts machen das ist ein technisches Problem. Vielleicht sollte ich mal, ich sollte mal schneiden vielleicht, dann klinge ich auch mal schlagfertig mit Ludlings träge. Aber das ist auch irgendwie so ein sympathisches Problem der modernen Zeit, weil jetzt wo jeder podcasten kann, können es auch die, die technisch dazu eigentlich gar nicht in der Lage sind. Die es eigentlich gar nicht sollten. Die es eigentlich vielleicht gar nicht sollten, genau. Im anderen Universum hätten sie es nicht gesoldet am besten. Was sind unsere Themen heute, Florenti? Mensch, wir haben heute wieder den Sack vollgestopft mit tollen Themen. Unfassbar. Wir haben über die Feiertage Pickepacke uns was überlegt, uns überlegt, was können wir machen. Und zwar, wir planen, ich glaube, jetzt kann man sagen, wir planen ja schon länger einen Mediumwechsel, Mediumswechsel. Medium. Mediums, genau, Medium, da kann man auch mal viel drüber reden, diese Alginmarke. Finde ich auch, Medium ist der Hammer. Ich glaube, ich hatte früher alles von Medionwechsel, Mediumswechsel. Medion. Medions, genau. Medion, da kann man auch mal viel drüber reden, diese Algemake. Ich glaube, ich hatte früher alles von Medion. Ich auch. Ich habe sogar immer noch einen Handyvertrag von Medion. Tatsächlich steht bei mir Medion Mobile links oben für 0,1 Cent pro Minute, pro halbe Stunde, glaube ich, koste das. Und du hast ein Prepaid-Handy, das kann man auch mal verraten. Du hast ein Prepaid-Handy. Ich habe noch ein Prepaid-Handy, ja. Warum hat man so ein Prepaid-Handy? Hat man wesentlich mehr Vorteile, wenn man direkt einen Vertrag hat und du verdienst ja auch nicht so schlecht bei Springer. Ne, ich habe es einfach nie geändert und tatsächlich, ich telefoniere sehr wenig, die Leute, klar, die Leute sehen mich, denken, oh, kommunikativer Typ, der hat bestimmt viele Freunde, ist tatsächlich nicht so. Ich rede eigentlich kaum, nur mit meinem Anwalt ab und zu, aber ansonsten eigentlich kaum und deswegen hat sie das nicht geändert, aber ist natürlich schon scheiße, weil wir konnten, also Thema, ich möchte mal jetzt ein Seitenthema eröffnen, Thema Unprofessionalität, weil ich finde, dann kennen wir das recht gut aus. Und es passt auch ganz gut zu unseren Themen, denn also ich glaube, unprofessioneller als eine Mail, ja, ich konnte sie gerade nicht zurückrufen, mein Prepaid-Guthaben ist leer, glaube ich, gibt es nicht. Das ist schon, glaube ich, Rockbottom. Ja, aber ist ein Gag. Ich glaube, ein Gag ist ein Ankommer bei den Leuten. Weil ich glaube, die trauen jetzt nicht zu, dass sie wirklich ein Prepaid-Ernäher haben. Wenn die Wahrheit lustiger ist als der lustigste Witz. Ja, das ist mein Leben. Aber ich habe mal gelesen, dass Gag auch immer Wahrheit ist. Also wenn man manchmal die Wahrheit sagt, ist auch einfach lustig. Ja, das mag sein. aber heute hatte ich auch eine E-Mail-Korrespondenz mit jemandem
und wo mir aufgefallen ist, Moment mal,
die E-Mail-Adresse, an die der geschrieben hat,
geht seit zwei Wochen nicht mehr.
Das heißt, wenn er sich jetzt gemeldet hat in der Zeit,
kann er sich nicht melden. Das heißt, ich habe mir eine andere
E-Mail-Adresse, die auch nicht meinen Namen beinhaltet,
du kennst sie, die nicht meinen Namen
beinhaltet, angeschrieben und so, hey,
lustige Sache, mir ist gerade aufgefallen,
dass meine E-Mail-Adresse seit zwei Wochen nicht mehr funktioniert. Und also das ist auch so Rock-Bottom-Professionalität, schlechter geht es nicht mehr, das ist der schlechtmöglichste Eindruck. Apropos Mails, nochmal, das ist auch ein schönes Thema, hatten wir glaube ich auch noch nicht. Gut, ja. Ich schreibe gerade Projektarbeiten, ich habe auch gerade die Projektarbeit unterbrochen für diesen Scheiss hier, Podcast-Ufo, und ich musste in der Tat an VW schreiben,
weil ich mache eine Projektarbeit über Humor und Marketing und wollte die VW-Spots vergleichen,
weil die ja hier, die hatten ja diese The Force-Spot, diesen lustigen, mit dem lustigen Star Wars-Jungen,
und da habe ich mir gedacht, komm, die schreibst du mal an, die sind bestimmt cool,
und dann habe ich den, dann konnte man halt nicht an eine E-Mail-Adresse schreiben,
weil die haben halt nur so Kontaktformulare.
Und dann habe ich halt an alle Abteilungen so einen Kontaktformular ausgebildet. Weil es ist halt, du musst dann halt entweder an International Marketing oder National Marketing, da dachte ich mir einfach, komm, scheiss drauf, einfach allen geschrieben. Aber es kommt sowieso alles bei derselben Praktikantin an, machen wir uns so nichts vor. Und die hat mir sehr fies zurückgeschrieben, so, ja, wir haben irgendwie 50 Mitarbeiter damit, waren damit beschäftigt irgendwie und ist alles bei mir angekommen. Ja, aber was ist ja auch, da habe ich mir auch gesagt, warum machen die das dann nicht mit richtigen Mailadressen, wo man dann selber entscheiden kann, wie man schreibt. Aber du hast ja auch von dir aus mit mehreren E-Mail-Adressen geschrieben, oder, nehme ich mal an. Ja klar. Also an jeder, mit jeder von deinen nochmal. Genau, auch mit anderen Namen teilweise, dass ich völlig verwirrt war. Du hast jetzt so nonchalant nebenbei in einem Satz so ein bisschen weggenuschelt, um ganz ehrlich zu sein, das Wort Projektarbeit benutzt. Jetzt werden wir hauptsächlich von Leuten gehört, die Hartz IV beziehen und deren bester Freund ein Kaktus ist. Jetzt führe uns noch mal ganz kurz ein in die akademische Welt. Was ist denn eine Projektarbeit? Das Gute ist ja, wir schreiben nicht nur Klausuren, also die normalen Examen, wo man für lernen muss und dann Multiple-Choice-Scheiss und so Kästchen reinschreiben muss und so was. Wir schreiben auch Projektarbeiten. Also ich studiere Journalismus, das ist was Kommunikatives und genau, das habe ich mir auch erst getan. Und dann ist es so, dass man dann irgendwie so ein Thema bekommt, wo man sich dann eine wissenschaftliche Arbeit überlegen kann, wo man dann auf 15 Seiten sich irgendwas zusammen mogelt und dann aus der Literatur hier mal ein Zitat aus dem Kontext reißt und hier mal ein Zitat aus dem Kontext reißt und dann macht man daraus, erfindet man, denkt man, am Ende hat man was Unglaubiges geleistet, aber eigentlich hat man sich alles nur zusammengelogen und am Ende kommt man auf ein Ergebnis, was es eigentlich gar nicht sein kann. Aber man hat es sehr gut begründet. Man hat eine These und sucht einfach so lange in der Literatur, bis man seine These ausreichend erfüllt. Ja, und man reißt auch einfach komplett alle Zitate aus dem Kontext und biegt sich die so hin irgendwie. Und da habe ich auch jetzt, wie gesagt, Humor und Marketing und dann habe ich das zwischen Deutschland und USA vergleichen, verglochen. Und da habe ich dann herausgefunden, das habe ich wirklich gelesen, das Zitat, dass die deutsche Sprache macht Punchlines schwierig. Aha, wie soll das denn? Die meisten amerikanischen Unternehmen, die synchronisieren gar nicht jetzt überall auf Deutsch, sondern machen einfach eine komplett neue Werbung, weil man das nicht richtig lustig ummünzen kann auf Deutsch. Hat das mit der Grammatik zu tun, dass das Wort am Ende nicht steht? Weil die Panksteine muss ja möglichst am Ende sein. Ja genau, weil es muss ja eigentlich eine Art Überraschung sein, dass am Ende was kommt, was man nicht erwartet hat im Laufe des Satzes. Und die deutsche Sprache wäre wohl so detailliert, dass man von vornherein schon weiss, wohin es geht, die Richtung. Und das ist, das sagt ihm ja auch für uns eine gute Rechtfertigung Das ist super. Also wir reden deutsch und es kann einfach nicht lustig werden. Und mit so einer Einstellung da reinzugehen, ist doch gut. Beziehungsweise die Leute wissen jetzt schon den Gag und müssen gar nicht auf die Pointe warten und können jetzt schon ausschalten eigentlich. Genau, die können jetzt schon ausschalten. Das ist für ein Service-Podcast. Ja, das sind Projektarbeiten jedenfalls. Musstest du auch auch Projektarbeiten schreiben, eigentlich? Du hast Philosophie mal studiert, ne?
Ja, ich habe mal eine, war das eine Essay oder eine Facharbeit, glaube ich, oder irgendwie sowas in der Richtung, auch zehn oder fünfzehn Seiten habe ich geschrieben über Freiheit. Und? Ist gut, ist was Gutes. Ja, genau, Fazit, gut. Nee, ja, hat ganz gut funktioniert. Das war das einige Mal, wo ich mir in meinem Studium richtig in ein Thema reingearbeitet habe und hat auch ganz gut funktioniert. Ein paar Gags natürlich eingebaut hier und da, die wurden nicht so ganz verstanden. Nee, die kommen wir nicht wieder an. Natürlich, das kann man nicht machen. Aber ich habe einen sehr realitätsnahen Approach genommen und ich glaube, das kam ganz kurz ein. 1,3. Das ist natürlich sehr gut. Aber natürlich... Auch sehr sympathisch, dass du diese Note im Nebensatz erwähnt hast.
Apropos sympathisch, unser Thema heute Sat.1.
Nein.
Nein?
Was? Hat man nicht... Kabel 1.
Kabel 1, Scheiße. Aber diese Zahlen bei Fernsehsendern sind ja auch ein bisschen willkürlich, oder?
Was ist eigentlich die höchste Zahl?
Die kommen auch aus.
Ja, das ist eine sehr gute Frage. Alpha 99. Ich glaube, Tele 5 ist schon die höchste, oder? Mhm, Tele 5. Gibt es was mit 6? Kabel 1, 6, 6, 6, 6. Gibt es sehr viele Einser? 6 gibt es. Na ja, na ja. Aber das wurde schon so gebaut mit dem Hintergrund einer Fernbedienung im Kopf, oder? Ja, genau. Es war ja damals so … Pro sieben natürlich, sieben ist mehr als fünf. Ja, sehr gut. Man hat ja nur irgendwie so zwei, drei irgendwie Sender und die wurden dann auch direkt nominiert. Also das erste halt, dann das zweite deutsche Fernsehen, ZDF und dann die dritten, sagt man ja, zu WDR und so. Das hatten ja nicht alle Empfang, man hat nur WDR zum Beispiel NRW-Empfang und daher angeblich die Zahlen behalten, was ein bisschen dämlich ist jetzt, wo eh alle Zahlen anders sind. Was sich bei den Bauern im Podcast-Business tatsächlich noch nicht durchgesetzt hat, aber ich glaube, das dauert nicht mehr lange. Ich finde, wir sollten einen Start machen, aber wir wissen auch nicht, auf welche Nummer wir wären. Was ist die beste Nummer? Also eins nicht, eins ist, wenn ich zu... Sieben ist schon gut. Es gibt ja Radio eins, gibt es ja schon. Genau, Radio eins, Radio zwei. Ich glaube, Radio drei gibt es auch, Bayern drei. Aber ich finde, sieben ist eine super Zahl, hier auch mit biblischem Hintergrund und so. Unglückszahl, würde ich sehr, ganz freilich sein. Dreizehn, radio dreizehn. Ich wäre für die Neuen, für die gute alte Neuen. Ich finde, wir sind ein Neuner-Podcast. Wir haben was von der Neuen. So ein bisschen bauchig, ein bisschen ...
Hast du als Kind auch immer Emotionen in Zahlen gelesen?
Ja. Ich finde zum Beispiel, die Sieben sieht total fies aus. Ja, die ist ein bisschen frech. Die fand ich sehr gut. Die ist aber irgendwie sympathisch. Die Sieben, die echte immer so ein bisschen an. Und neben dieser Spiesser-Sechs und der lustigen Acht, der gemütlichen Acht, genau, der gemütlichen Onkel Acht, da kommt die Sieben immer gut an, fand ich. Ich finde, die Neun hatte irgendwie so was Erhabenes, irgendwie so wie so ein Stativ, auf dem sie stehen und oben so ein Ball. Aber die Neun will immer mehr sein, die Neun wollte immer schon die Zehn sein. Will sich erheben, ja. Tatsächlich, die Fünf ist für mich auch so ein harter Punkt, irgendwie Fünf fand ich auch immer sehr unsympathisch. Nee, nee, nee. Die hat was Beissendes, irgendwas Knackiges. Die eins fand ich immer super. Eins ist gut. Nummer eins, Nummer eins. Ich habe die zwei auch immer ganz gerne geschrieben, weil früher als Kind muss man ja aus irgendeinem Grund irgendeinen Scheiss lernen, den es in der echten Welt gar nicht gibt, wie zum Beispiel Schreibschrift und sowas. Und da auch immer die zwei mit so einem Kringel noch unten. Ja, genau. Wo man sich auch fragt, warum, was soll das denn? Den fand ich super schön. Ich habe auch gerne eine Kuh gemalt und bei der Kuh, das Kuh hat ja unten diesen Schlenker drin. Wirklich? Fand ich immer ganz toll. Und irgendwann, irgendwann fand ich immer so geil, da konnte ich dann alle kleinen Buchstaben in der Schreibschrift und die fand ich immer cooler irgendwie als die grossen. Und dann habe ich mal aus Spaß ein ganzes Diktat einfach nur klein geschrieben, weil ich es schön fand. Und das war mein erster weinender Smiley, den ich bekommen habe. Und dann war die Heuterei aber groß, kann ich nicht sagen. Oh, oh, oh, oh. Ich habe mich dann wirklich rechtfertigen wollen. Ich habe wirklich dann weinend vor der Lehrerin gesessen, ja, aber die kleinen Buschami sind doch viel schöner. Was eine relativ dämliche Ausrede ist, aber das fängt im Nachhinein erst auf. Ja, finde ich gut. Benutzt du das heute noch als Ausrede? Ja. So falsch geparkt irgendwie. Ja, ich fand das schön. Ja, genau, das sieht einfach, wenn man sich die Skyline anguckt, das Parkplatz ist, ist so viel schöner einfach. Nee, läuft nicht mehr gut. Aber Kindheitserinnerungen sind ganz toll. Meine Mutter hat einen Wunschzettel von mir gefunden, den ich damals mal an das Christkind geschrieben habe. Aha. Das war wahnsinnig toll. Ich habe mir gew gewünscht einen Arztkoffer, habe den auch gemalt daneben, dann eine Ritterburg, aber als Spielzeug. Ganz wichtig. Damit das Christkind das auch ja richtig versteht. Ich wollte ja nicht, dass irgendwie meine Eltern sich so Mühe machen und eine richtige Ritterburg besorgen, das tat mir leid. Deswegen habe ich geschrieben, Ritterburg aber als Spielzeug und Pfeil und Bogen, aber mit 17 Pfeilen aber unbedingt. Ach, warum genau 17? Das war, ich weiß nicht, im Nachhinein ein bisschen gruselig, so für meine 17 Todesfeinde. Ich habe eine 17 Leute auf meiner Liste. Das ist genau so mit den Gangschaltungen von Fahrrädern. Das war für mich immer auch eine sehr willkürliche Zahl irgendwie. Unfassbar geil. Aber auch sehr willkürlich. Irgendwann hatte ich mein neues Fahrrad, da hatte ich irgendwie Milliarden Gänge. Ich wusste nicht, wohin damit. Ich wusste nicht, wohin damit. Die meisten habe ich nie benutzt tatsächlich, um ganz ehrlich zu sein. Ich bin immer nur, dann hattest du so Fahrräder auch, wo du links drei hast und rechts dann jeweils in diesen drei Gangarten irgendwie sieben hattest oder so, so sieben Gänge und dann also 21 insgesamt und das war viel zu viel einfach für mich, immer schon. Und dann bin ich irgendwie nur in sieben gefahren, maximal, aber das ist auch schon glaube ich falsch. Mein Fahrrad war noch relativ oft kaputt, weil ich glaube, ich mal mit dem falschen Gang gefahren bin. Mir ist das zu viel Luke Mockridge gerade, diese Kindheit der Erinnerung neunziger. Nein, mir gefällt das nicht. Ich will, dass wir ein bisschen edgy sind, nach vorne schauen und nicht immer nach hinten, hey, erinnert euch noch an die Turtles. Nein, wir gucken nach vorne. Wie muss man sich, wie muss man sich, Floreorentin will im neuen Jahr vorstellen? Ach, halt die Fresse einfach. Ja, ich weiss nicht, du bist ja weg vom Anekdotischen, aber ich fliege morgen nach Tübingen, so. Tübingen? Ja, und werde dort interviewt und ganz toll und soll ich da meine Expertise präsentieren, was ich natürlich gerne tue. Du bist interviewt? Wer will dich hier interviewen, bitte? Ich weiss noch nicht ganz genau, die E-Mails, die ich bekommen habe, sind anonym. Aber mal sehen, was mich dort erwarten wird. Ich freue mich auf jeden Fall.
Wofür ist Tübingen bekannt?
Gute Frage. Ich habe irgendwie bei Tübingen immer irgendwas im Kopf.
Ich glaube, irgendeine Schulkollegin studiert da. Aber es könnte auch was ganz anderes sein, dass mein Unterbewusstsein mir da einen fiesen Streich spielt und mein Erzfeind wohnt da oder irgendwie sowas in der Richtung.
Ah, Tübingen. Ich verbinde nichts mit Tübingen, außer dass es klingt wie Thüringen. Das ist eigentlich das Einzige, was ich mit dem Verbinde. So die Kartei in deinem Gehirn, die Schublade mit auf, dann ist so ein kleiner, ich stelle das Löschblatt, wo du so ganz groß draufkriegst, das klingt ähnlich wie Thüringen. Ja, mehr habe ich nicht. In meinem Kopf ist es rot unterstrichen. Ja, genau. Wegen dem Ingen, ja. Tübingen, das sagt mir gar nichts. Ich mag Städte auch nicht, die für nichts bekannt sind, irgendwie.
Nee, das ist lame.
Von vornherein unsympathisch.
Nee, das ist absolut lame, aber da kann ich vielleicht nächstes Mal davon mehr erzählen.
Und jetzt ist es natürlich so eine Vorschau, nur so ein kleiner Teaser, nur so ein kleiner Teaser.
Aber wir wollen ja ins Fernsehen, ne? Wir sind ja, sag ich mal, geboren fürs Fernsehen, dieses Podcast ist ja nur ein reiner Lückenfüller.
Ein unangenehmes Sprungbrett.
Ja, dass es ein bisschen kratzig ist, dass man nicht weiss, man denkt sich, man steht mit den Füssen drauf und denkt, das ist ganz schön kratzig,
Wenn man sich... ist ja nur ein reiner Lückenfüller. Ein unangenehmes Sprungbrett. Ja, dass es ein bisschen kratzig ist. Man steht mit den Füßen drauf und denkt, das ist ganz schön kratzig. Und es ist auch schon sehr alt. Es klappt auch nicht richtig. Und man kommt auch nicht wirklich hoch damit. Kennst du diese Sprungbretter aus der Schule? Wer hat denn auch so Sprungbretter, da muss man so Übungen machen und dann über Dinge springen. Luke. Luke. Achso, Entschuldigung. Luke und Trug. Luke und Trug, wir sind keine Luke und Trug-Folge, wollen wir nicht. Auf jeden Fall, wir wollen ins Fernsehen. Ach, du machst die Überleitung schon die ganze Zeit. Ja, natürlich. Wir wollen ins Fernsehen, will man auch ins Fernsehen eigentlich, oder will man von der Reihe im Internet bleiben? Das ist nur die Frage, die sich viele Leute stellen. Das ist eine gute Frage, ja, aber ich glaube, gerade wir beide sind, glaube ich, eine sehr visuelle Kombination. Ich glaube, wir funktionieren sehr gut visuell. Wir sind Bild, was fürs Auge. Was fürs Auge. Auch weil wir vom Ton her nicht so viel zu bieten haben. Deswegen, glaube ich, können wir mehr rausreissen mit dem Auge. Aber ich sage mal... Auch, übrigens auch was, was ich herausgefunden habe bei dieser Projektarbeit. Die Deutschen stehen auf körperlichem Humor. Und zwar kommt das daher, dass die Sprache halt so scheisse ist für Gags. Ohne Scheiss. Man muss irgendwie ausweichen. Ja, genau. Und deswegen stehen die auf körperlichen Humor. Und das ist ja auch eigentlich erkennbar, weil diese ganzen Samstagabendshows, wo es dann in Amerika viele Comedy-Shows gibt, Saturday Nightlife und so, gibt es halt hier das, wo halt immer die Wetten waren und immer so ein bisschen belustigt wurden. Dann gibt es diese Quizze, wo Johannes Bekerner irgendwie, ich weiß nicht, Johannes Liefers oder so, Jan Joseph, diese Vornamen aus ganz vielen Jotze sind mir nicht eingeschaut, Jan Joseph Liefers, der dann irgendwie, ich weiß nicht, Memory spielt oder so, oder halt viel mit Körper macht, Twister spielt, Twister spielt mit Anna los, ja sowas. Das ist halt typisch Samstagabend im deutschen Fernsehen. So weisst du, Brumm die Traktorschau. Ja, genau. Alles so körperlich und so, das ist halt typisch deutsch. Wie bin ich da jetzt auch willkommen? Weil wir ein visuelles Format sind. Wir sind was visuelles, wir sind für körperlich, genau. Das ist, glaube ich, was für uns. Ich bin ja, also ein Fan von Fernsehen kann man ja eigentlich nicht sein, weil Fernsehen für mich immer irgendwas Fremdes hatte, weil ich mich nie wirklich viel mit Fernsehen beschäftigt hatte, weil ich habe als Kind irgendwie Zeichenrichtserien geschaut und dann relativ schnell schon nur noch Giga und sowas in der Richtung, aber so diese Wetten-Das-Phase nur als Kind und sowas, deswegen ist das für mich immer so ein altes Relikt. Und ich habe tatsächlich heute in der Recherche, weil wir haben, ich habe heute gerade schon mal einen Podcast aufgenommen, der nicht schlecht war, und da haben wir über eine Gottheit geredet. Ist egal warum, auf jeden Fall habe ich mir eine alte ... Nee, ist gar nicht egal. Nee, ist völlig egal, das funktioniert nicht. Auf jeden Fall gibt es auf BR Alpha kam früher so eine Fernsehreihe, wo immer ein gewisser Michael Kohlmeier die alten Mythologie erklärt hat, also dann so die Legende von Zeus und Eurydipes oder irgendwie so ein Scheiß.
Und ihr könnt euch das mal auf YouTube angucken, guckt einfach mal bei Michael Kohlmeier, die Sendung heisst irgendwie Mythologie und ganz geil finde ich da das Set. Und ich versuche es zu erklären, und zwar besteht dieses Set einfach nur aus einem blauen Raum, wo ein, ich würde jetzt einfach mal ein Moderationskatzenbaum steht. Das ist ein komplett abstraktes Gebilde, das nur dazu gemacht ist, damit der Moderator verschiedene Moderationsposen einnehmen kann. Er kann sich hinsetzen, er hat so einen Pult, da kann er sich hinstellen, da kann er sich so lässig auf seine Lehne legen. Also dieses Objekt wurde allein dafür gebaut, dass man damit moderieren kann. Aber BR Alpha, der war doch auch die Alpha Centauri mit Harald Lech schlief. Genau, in dem Klassenzimmer. Genau, und das ist ja auch so was, so ein Ding, das er eigentlich braucht. Ja, gut, aber es ist halt so ein Setting, du hast so ein Klassenzimmer, aber dieser Moderationskatzenbaum ist rein künstlich, da wurde ein Schreiner engagiert, hat gesagt, bau mal was, worauf man gut moderieren kann, und das finde ich so absurd. Ist das so was, was in so kleinen Kommunen im Kreisverkehren steht? Ja, das kann gut sein. Da liegen dann so ein paar Bücher. Aber es ist wirklich, das könnte man sich nicht in eine Wohnung stellen, weil es komplett nutzlos ist. Es ist nur dafür gedacht, okay, wir haben vier verschiedene Kamerawinkel, in jeder hast du eine andere Körperhaltung. Und das allein finde ich so obskur und so seltsam, aber irgendwie schon wieder cool, weil der ist auch total, der ist ein Virtuoser an diesem Gerät, der steht auf und dann lehnt er sich dran und dann stützt er sich ab und dann Handy in die Hosentasche, weil der 15 Minuten lang redet er einfach nur. Er erzählt, da passiert nichts, kein Schlecht, gar nichts. Anscheinend haben die bei BR Alpha so einen Fimmel dafür. Das stimmt. Was war das eigentlich für ein Sender? Wieso BR Alpha eigentlich? Ganz komisch, ganz strange. Da finde ich ProSieben Sat.1 Bär-Alpha. Das waren so ein bisschen so ein Outsider schon. Das wären so die, die in der Herstreihe gesessen haben. Das ist intellektuell. Aber ich meine, ich habe nur die Vorstellung, ich hatte ja schon lange eine Katze, aber noch nie einen Katzenbaum oder so ein Katzenspiel-Ding. Wie geil es für so eine Katze sein muss, zu sehen, ich habe hier so ein Gerät, das erfüllt alle meine Wünsche auf einmal. Ein Gerät? Ich kann hier an so einem Ding schwingen, ich kann hier kratzen, ich kann da raufhüpfen, dieses Ding ist unfassbar gut. Bisschen so wie eine Multifunktionsfernbedingung für mich. Ja, genau, total. Aber ich meine, deswegen glaubst du ja an einen Gott, weil die Katze denkt sich, das kann ja kein Zufall sein, dass hier so ein Gerät steht, das alle meine Träume, die ich habe, auf einmal erfüllen kann. Das kann doch nicht sein. Ich glaube, Katzen sind sehr religiöse Tiere, weil sie müssen sich denken, ich meine, jeden Tag um zwölf Uhr steht da was zu essen, das kann doch nicht wahr sein, das ist zu gut, um wahr zu sein. Genau, das stimmt. Die glauben an so eine Gottheit, aber die sehen die Gottheit ja immer, weil die Gottheit streichelt das ja auch und so. Das ist eine ziemlich lame Gottheit. Aber für die ist die Welt so perfekt. Alles, was sie sehen, ist perfekt auf sie zu gestimmen. Du glaubst, dass für Tiere, für Haustiere die Welt perfekt ist? Also für meine Fische damals war die Welt nicht perfekt. Das war eine grausame Welt, das war die Hölle auf Erden. Tja, apropos, wo wir gerade bei Dingen Lebewesen in der Wohnung sind, meine Pflanze, ich bin jetzt wieder in meiner Wohnung in Köln und bin jetzt irgendwie seit drei Wochen mal wieder hier und habe vergessen, meine Pflanzen mitzunehmen, ich hätte die auch nicht mitgenommen, aber ich hätte die auch nicht mitgenommen, aber ich hätte gedacht, dass ich das auch zu unter. Das vergessen sie wegzuschmeißen. Naja, genau, einfach sie ist völlig schwarz und eingegangen, die letzte fleischfrestete Pflanze hier. Es ist sehr traurig, das ist sehr traurig. Aber kannst du dir nicht auch so eine Fressnapf hinstellen oder sowas? Habe ich auch überlegt, aber die sind zu dumm. Pflanzen sind zu dumm. Sie sind zu doof einfach. Ja, ich habe zu Weihnachten jetzt so künstliche Pflanzen geschenkt bekommen. Ja, das ist schon traurig. Das ist tatsächlich traurig. Ein Handtuchhalter und künstliche Pflanzen habe ich geschenkt bekommen. Das war mal an Weihnachten. Das ist schon scheiße eigentlich. Ein Handtuchhalter. Der braucht sich, der ist sehr sinnvoll. Der ist sehr sinnvoll, ja. Handtuchhalter sollte jeder haben. Ich habe tatsächlich keinen Handtuchhalter. Ich bin in einer Wohngemeinschaft mit einem Mitbewohner tatsächlich und ich bin sehr faul und nehme am haushaltlichen Dasein überhaupt nicht teil, aber eine Sache habe ich eingebaut ins Bad, mein Mitbewohner irgendwie Waschmaschine und Badewanne und Verschluss und Dichtungsring und ich habe eine Sache gebaut, den Handuchhalter und er musste einfach so zwei Stangen, die man an die Fliese kleben musste, mit so einem Superkleber, der dabei war, innerhalb von zwei Wochen abgebrochen, innerhalb von zwei Wochen kaputt, liegt jetzt unbenutzt in der Ecke und wir hängen jetzt unsere Handtücher über die Vorhangstange der Badewanne und das war's. Das einzige,
was ich eingebaut habe, ist sofort kaputt gegangen.
Das ist auch bei mir lustig.
Bei mir war kein Platz für so eine Stange über der Badewanne, weil
die quasi auf einer Achse
mit der Tür liegt. Verstehst du?
Das ist sehr schwierig zu erklären, sehr schwierig
vorzustellen, aber man kann jedenfalls keine Stange
oben haben, sondern man muss so eine
L-Form quasi braucht man als Stange. Und deswegen habe ich mir so ein Rollo gekauft. Also ich habe keinen Duschvorhang quasi, sondern so ein Rollo. Was? Das ist total geil. Das ist quasi wie so eine Wand, die du runterfahren kannst. Also du hast so eine Band, so eine Kordel, die ziehst du und dann kommt so ein Duschvorhang. Eine Kurbel, an der musst du kurbeln. Ja, genau. Das ist total geil. What? Ja, was es für Dinge gibt, ey, das ist der Hammer. Und als ich dann in den Baumarkt gefahren bin, dann fragte ich, ob es sowas gibt überhaupt, weil es noch nie in meinem Leben vorgekommen ist, irgendwie sowas, haben die gesagt, ja, klar, hier. Da war ich voll erstaunt, wie viele Dinge es gibt, von denen man gar nicht weiss. Ja. Das ist der Hammer. Die Welt ist der Hammer. Aber für Katzen ist die Welt auch nicht der Hammer. Doch, total gut. Alles, was sie machen, ist genau für ihre Wünsche geschaffen. Alles, was sie haben. Sie haben eine perfekte Decke, die ganze Welt ist ein grosses Bett. Schau mal, so ein Sofa, was so ein Sofa für eine Katze sein muss, ist der absolute Himmel. Ich meine, normalerweise denkst du, als ein Bett ist in etwa ungefähr so gross wie ich, nicht bei Katzen. Da ist das Bett 50 mal so gross., das ist doch unfassbar. Und egal wo die sich hinlegen, die können sich ja auch auf Nägel legen zum Beispiel, das ist ja, das fühlt sich ja immer irgendwie gut an für die, weil die auch ein Fell haben halt. Ja, das stimmt, die sind ihr eigenes Bett eigentlich schon. Ich finde diese Katzen-Fail-Videos, die sagen doch irgendwie, es rauscht gerade hier. Naja, aber diese Katzen-Fail-Videos sagen doch viel darüber aus, dass Katzen auch nicht immer geiles Leben haben. Ich finde, wenn Katzen sich verkalkulieren und ihnen gegen Schrank springen, sieht es immer ziemlich dämlich aus. Weil man erwartet von denen, die Erwartungshaltung bei Katzen ist, dass sie immer perfekt landen, perfekt aussehen, dass sie keinen Flecken im Fell haben und nicht gegen Schränke springen. Ich glaube, deswegen sind Katzen-Fail-Videos ja auch so beliebt, weil man sieht, dass sie nicht perfekt sind. Und sie tun so, als wären sie perfekt, aber eigentlich sind sie es auch nicht. Deswegen ist es ja eigentlich interessant. Wie wir eigentlich. Es gibt ja wahrscheinlich, ich weiß nicht, wahrscheinlich gibt es ähnlich viele Katzen wie Hunde, aber es gibt keine Hunde-Fail-Videos. Katzen sind unendlich vielmal beliebter, einfach weil es diese Genugtuung ist, die Genugtuung ist, irgendwie so ein arrogantes Arschloch fallen zu sehen, wohingegen ein Hund, der ist irgendwie immer gut drauf und ich bin ein besser Freund. Bisschen treu doof, das tut einem noch mal leid. Ich finde Hunde auch total langweilig, weil du willst niemanden haben, der dich immer mag. Dass dich jemand mag, ist nur dadurch wertvoll, dass es auch Situationen gibt, in denen dich die Person nicht mag. Klassisch ist das Yin und Yang, simple. Die Frage, die du eben gestellt hast, gibt es mehr Hunde oder mehr Katzen? Ich glaube, warte mal, einen Moment, ich muss kurz mal jetzt... Was genau googelst du jetzt? Das ist die Frage. Ich google jetzt, gibt es mehr Hunde oder Katzen? Den gesamten Satz. Hund oder Katze, was ist das bessere Haustier? Gibt es mehr Katzen oder Hunde? Gibt es mehr Katzen oder Hunde? Ich war immer auf bild.de, um diese Frage zu beantworten, weil die so einen Artikel darüber hatten, und dann kam so eine Katze auf mein Ohr eben. Die haben neuerdings so Surround-Sounds für Dinge, die mit Artikeln sind. Ja, das ist das Beste, Leute. Wenn ihr irgendwie eine Website bauen wollt, dann auf jeden Fall Sounds, die abgespielt werden, wenn man auf die Seite geht. Ungefreit abgespielt werden. Aber das ist doch wirklich seit Jahren ist das doch die Standardrepertoire von Dinge, die ich hasse. Bei allen Steckbriefen, die irgendwie Viertklässler in der Schule machen müssen, was ich liebe und was ich hasse, steht bei Ich hasse immer Spinat, Jungs, Hitler und Webseiten, bei denen Musik abgespielt wird. Warum raffen das Webdesigner nicht, dass das keiner mag?
Ich verstehe auch nicht, das sind auch so Dinge, die nicht zusammenpassen. Also man will ja was lesen, aber man kriegt was auf die Ohren, das will man ja auch nicht. Das ist wie diese Diddle, diese Diddle-Briefpapiere damals, die gerochen haben. Boah Gott! Das ist ja genau das gleiche. Du willst was lesen, was irgendwer geschrieben hat, so willst du mit mir gehen, ja dann vielleicht, und du riechst was, das erwartest du ja nicht. Aussßer du kannst die gesamte Botschaft riechen, außer die Botschaft ist als Geruch kodiert, dann klar, dann. Das wäre auch gut, das wäre ganz schön gut, aber leider nicht möglich. Ich habe hier gerade einen Artikel gefunden, das Verhältnis von Hund und Katze ein für allemal geklärt, aber dabei meinen sie Verhältnis wie ein zwischenmenschliches Verhältnis, so dass sie sich nicht mögen, wo ich mir auch dachte, fuck you, Alter. Das ist der Hammer, das ist Clickbaiting auf höchstem Niveau. Ja, alle Leute, die die, ich habe jetzt gegoogelt, Deutschland Hund-Katze-Verhältnis und finde nur solche, wie gut passen Hunde zu Katzen, shit. Naja, vielleicht Verhältnis, vielleicht ist das nicht das richtige Wort. Denkst du jetzt zu englisch. Google hat aber heute auch echt einen schlechten Tag, ohne Witz. Manchmal hat Google auch so Tage, wo man sich denkt, Leute, strengt euch ein bisschen an. Ja, genau. Da passiert echt gar nichts. Google ist aber eigentlich auch trotzdem immer noch gut. Google hat ein gutes Leben, muss man mal sagen. Oh, ich muss noch meinen Google-Werbevertrag, mich erinnern. Google benutzt eigentlich irgendwer an dieser Scheißwelt Bing? Ich habe tatsächlich einmal, oh Gott, das ist so unangenehm, aber das ist tatsächlich passiert, weil wir hatten ja in der Frank-Elsa-Masterclass, wo ich auch zu einem Journalisten ausgebildet wurde, hatten wir auch mal einen englischen Typen von der BBC oder sowas und der hat uns Internetrecherche beigebracht und da hat uns dann lauter so Tricks und Hacker-Sachen und wonach man suchen muss und Und dann habe ich gesagt, so ja, manchmal, und dann ja, warum? Und dann habe ich gesagt, diesen Satz, der noch große Wellen schlagen wird, ja, bei Bing wird weniger zensiert. Und jetzt in allen meinen Klassenkollegen rattert im Kopf, was wird denn zensiert bei normalen Suchmaschinen? A, Kinderpornos, B, irgendwie krasse Gewalt-Superkrass-Videos und C, irgendwie Tierpornos. Also in welchen Situationen auch immer Florentin Will sich dazu bereit erklärt, Bing zu nutzen, sind Situationen, in denen er Interesse an ein dieser drei Dinge hat. Und das war mir überhaupt nicht bewusst, als ich das gesagt habe. Und dann, naja. Das ist ja total geil. Und bei allen bist du auf eine andere Ebene durchgeschossen. Genau, die einen sagen, was, er ist nekrophil, wusste ich gar nicht. Die einen halt nicht für den Kriminellen, die anderen für den Pädophilen. Aber das ist die schlechtmöglichste Antwort. Warum willst du Bing? Weil da weniger zensiert wird. Ja, das wird zu fucking recht zensiert, verdammt nochmal. Ja, ich, das ist gar nicht so. Ich weiss schon wieder, was du meinst, wahrscheinlich. Also, ich meine, bei Google, da wird, du wirst so gedacht haben, da werden Dinge nicht angezeigt, die vielleicht auch wichtig sein können für deine Recherche. Wie zum Beispiel. Genau, ja. So, nächstes Thema. Naja, finde ich jetzt nicht so. Finde ich ein bisschen peinlich, aber auch auf eine Art sympathisch. Ja, dankeschön. Das ist so der Titel meiner Biografie. Peinlich, aber auch sympathisch. Das ist ein gutes T-Shirt für dich, wäre es. Peinlich, aber auf eine Art sympathisch. Auf eine gewisse Art irgendwo schon ein bisschen sympathisch. Was gibt es noch? Bing gibt es noch? Yahoo? Naja, irgendwie alles Google ist schon das Beste, muss man sagen. Hattest du eigentlich vor Facebook, hattest du Lokalisten? Wir sind wieder im gefährlichen Luke-Mocklish-Niveau, ich versuche es kurz zu halten, aber Lokalisten, sag er das mal? Lokalisten, nee, wir hatten, ich komme ja aus dem Kreis Unna und wir hatten Unnaher, Unnaher.de. Das war, da ist wieder eine Kreativbombe explodiert, unnaher. Unnaher.de, und jetzt wusste auch keiner, wie man das ausspricht, ja, hey, bist du auf unna, unna, bist du auf diesem einen Portal, wo alle sind, es hat sich keiner getraut auszusprechen, weil keiner es jemals gesprochen gehört hat, weil das ja nicht so ein Video, wo dann die Macher sagen, ja, herzlich willkommen auf unnaher.de und das wusste keiner, so gebrochen wird. Da werden Soundbites auf der Seite wieder gut, dafür kann man es benutzen. Aber ich war bei Lokalisten und seit sechs Monaten kriege ich irgendwie jede Woche so eine Mail von Lokalisten, so, das ist diese Woche bei den Lokalisten passiert und die Mail hat immer den selben Inhalt, nichts, nichts, nichts. Das heißt, die schicken mir eine Mail, um mir zu sagen, dass nichts passiert ist. Ja, vielen Dank, danke schön. Da bin ich auch drauf gekommen. Das ist echt gut so. Jeder Konzern der Welt schickt dir eine Mail. Diese Woche ist nichts passiert. Ja, okay, gut zu wissen. Danke. Gott sei Dank. In so einer schnelllebigen Welt, wo jede Woche Scheiße passiert, ist es aber gut, wenn nichts passiert. Ist es eigentlich die grössere News, wenn nichts passiert. Ja, du hast völlig recht. Du hast echt, guck, du bist heute gut drauf. Nimm dich ja Öppel liefern, hau mal was raus jetzt, hau mal was raus. Mir ist es mal aufgefallen, ich habe jetzt mir ein neues Konto bei Amazon gemacht, um die Studenten-Prime-Vorteile noch ein weiteres Jahr nutzen zu können. Hoffentlich, hoffentlich, oh scheiße, darf man das sagen oder? Nein, auf gar keinen Fall. Macht doch jeder so auf eine Art und wir piepen uns einfach. Na jedenfalls kriege ich jetzt von jedem, jeden Tag von Amazon, ne jeden Tag kriege ich zehn Mails von Amazon, die irgendwie was runtergesetzt haben. Aber was ich gar nicht will, so Haushaltsgeräte, Fitnesslaufbänder und sowas. Ich glaube, Amazon will mich demütigen damit. Weil wir nur ein schlechtes Gewissen machen, ja. Ja, genau. Das ist genau wie Dating-Seiten. Also nach den Feiertagen einfach mal Laufbänder runtersetzen, Arschlöcher. Amazon ist auch ein Arschloch. Amazon ist ein richtiges Arschloch. Wir haben mal so ein, apropos Zukunft, wir wollen ja nicht in die Zukunft gucken, weil wir so Anti-Luc-Mockridge sind plötzlich. Deswegen, wir haben mal irgendwie ein Video geguckt im Studium, wo wir, da wurde darüber spekuliert, wie die Zukunft wohl aussieht und dass Unternehmen die Zukunft bestimmen und dass Unternehmen die neuen Länder sind irgendwann. Und da wurde spekuliert, dass Amazon mit Google zusammengeht. Und da heisst es Googleson und regiert die Welt. Oder Mugl. Also Googleson, genau. Ja, und das Googleson wird irgendwann die Welt beherrschen. Das war so der Konsens auch der Gruppe eigentlich. Wo man ein bisschen denkt, das ist scheisse, oder? Ihr hattet vor allem auch nicht recht, oder wie lange ist das Seminar schon her? Naja, gut, noch nicht so lange her. Es ging so um 2033 oder so, so um den Dreh. Sehr spezifisch. Was glaubt ihr, wie ist das in die Welt in 2037? Warum so genau? Nur so, überleg mal ruhig. Ich habe jetzt keine Aktien gekauft. Das ist ein kaltes Number. Naja, Google-Sonnen, also Leute, werden die sich fusionieren, irgendwann dann lieber fliehen. Ja, das war's von mir. Ja, vielen Dank, Stefan Titzel, zurück ins Studio. Titzel, wir hatten uns vielleicht auch andere Themen, warte mal, wir haben noch andere Themen. Ja, wir haben ja unsere Themen schon komplett ausgeschlachtet. Ach genau, wir sind ja auf Tele 5, wo wollen wir eigentlich eingehen. Ja, aber die Frage ist, ja, aber was braucht Tele 5? Also Tele 5 ist ja schon ein sehr gutes Konzept. Ja, was ist eigentlich, mal ganz kurz, mal ganz kurz, wofür genau steht Tele 5 eigentlich? Vor allem, ich verstehe auch diese selbe Tele nicht. Tele wie Telefon oder was? Mit Television, glaube ich. Aber ich verbinde Tele 5 nur mit Oliver Kalkofe und alten Bud Spencer-Filmen. Ja, wo passen wir da rein, ist die Frage. Wir sind doch eine Schnittmenge zwischen Bud Spencer und Kalkofe. Also wir sind mehr Bud Spencer als Kalkofe, aber das ist ja nicht schlecht. Ich habe mir folgendes Konzept überlegt, ich habe mir ein paar Gedanken gemacht. Und zwar glaube ich, der Schlüssel ist, dass man sich ein Format überlegt, das sich nicht nur auf gute Unterhaltung konzentriert, sondern vor allem auf viel Unterhaltung. Also gar nicht so sehr auf Qualität, sondern mehr auf Quantität. Also alle Gags quasi schruttflitten, schruttflitten Mechanik, alle Gags raus, an die ihm einfallen. Ganz viele Gags. Auch wenn manche vielleicht nicht unbedingt fürs Fernsehen geeignet sind oder vielleicht strafrechtlich relevant sind. Und alle fünf Sekunden neuer Impuls, ein Gesang, ein Tanz, ein Gag, irgendwie flackernde Farben, irgendwas in der Richtung. Einfach wahnsinnig viel Unterhaltung. Und das muss doch aufgehen. Das ist ein Konzept, finde ich, das ist zukunftsträchtig. Ich finde auch manchmal, wenn man so denkt, Brainstorming nicht ganz zu Ende gedacht, etwas, was lustig wäre, wenn man darüber redet, aber nicht lustig wäre, wenn man es sieht. Absolut, ja. Dass man einfach mal gar keine Sendung macht, einfach mal ein Schwarzbild die ganze Zeit hat, aber oben dieses Tele5-Logo und auch vielleicht Werbung macht. Ja, und dann ist es metamässig lustig. Sag mal, kennst du eigentlich DogTV? Dog? Wie Dog. Wie Dog. Genau, und das ist Und man denkt jetzt, okay, DogTV ist halt ein Fernsehsender für Hundebesitzer, da werden dann irgendwie Hundeleien getestet. Wie ich mir vorstelle, man macht eine GoPro auf einen Hund und schaltet von Hund zu Hund quasi. So stelle ich mir, ist es das? Nein, nein. Aber wäre lustig. Schreibt das mal auf unsere Telefonfile. Okay, warte, ich schreibe es auf. Also wie, also GoPro auf Hund und dann schneidet man das nicht her zwischen Hund und Katze. Und dann kann man das Verhältnis zwischen Hund und Katze beleuchern. Und das ist dann eine Minute lang lustig und danach nur noch nervig, weil Hund einfach den ganzen Tag, am meisten Tag nur noch rumliegt, die meisten Zeit das Tage. Und zwar ist DogTV Fernsehen für Hunde. Und es ist kein fucking Witz. Das ist Fernsehen, wo die Hunde Fernsehen schauen sollen. Und Hunde haben ja irgendwie ganz andere Augen als Menschen, die sehen ganz andere Farben. Die sehen ja keine Farben oder nicht. Das kann auch sein. Oder irgendwie Graustufen oder so. Das heißt, dieses Programm besteht hauptsächlich aus komplett psychodänischen Farben, die irgendwie rumflackern, irgendwelche Dinge, die durch die Luft fliegen, irgendwie so ein Hund, der am Strand steht und dann wackelt alles, total psychodelische Klänge und eh, eh, eh, eh, eh, eh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, Keyboard zusammenklappert, ja, das wird Hunden schon gefallen, weil wer weiss denn schon, was fucking Hunden gefällt. Also das ist so absurd, aber die Idee ist gut. Die Idee ist gut, aber für den Cutter, der irgendwie das Programm zusammenschneiden muss, tut mir auch ein bisschen leid. Soll ich dir noch fünf Sekunden länger auf dem Hund bleiben, der sich in der Luft dreht? Ne, ne, schneid, schneid weg, schneid weg. Schneid weg und am Ende des Tages, ja, Schatz, ich muss schon wieder Hunde schneiden.
Oh nein, ja, leg dich hin.
Wollen wir da nicht auf die Tröte reiten?
Nee, nee, nee, wir hatten schon drei Tröten in der letzten Minute.
Das ist nicht gut. Warum denn?
Ja, gut, keine Ahnung, gut, hau noch eine Tröte rein.
Komplett ins Leere Stocher.
Die sind sich drehenden Knochen, der langsam in so eine Kaleidoskopartig verschwimmt. Sollen wir da drauf bleiben oder sollen wir lieber weggehen? Schneid weg, schneid weg, wir gehen auf die Eins. Oh Gott, weg damit! Das ist ganz schön geil. Aber das ist schon geil. Für einen Zuschauerprogramm… Marktlücke, Marktlücke, Fisch-TV. Podcast für Hunde. Fisch-TV. Ich glaube, für meine Fische damals wäre alles andere als das, als der Blick in mein Zimmer besser gewesen.
Aber das ist eine Vorstellung, du erstellst ein Programm für nicht mal dieselbe Spezies. Du hast keine Ahnung, ob das auch nur irgendwie ankommt, ob dein Zuschauer das überhaupt versteht. Ja, aber das ist Fernsehen ja auch. ZDF, da machen mit Dreissiger, machen Fernsehen für Ende Neunziger, die vom Fernsehen vegetieren und auch nicht mehr richtig leben. Und das ist wie eine andere Speziesis, auch Werbung für wie eine andere Speziesis. Die man eigentlich auch DogTV zeigen könnte, im Grunde macht es keinen Unterschied. Ob das Helene Fischer sich dreht und flackert oder irgendwie so eine Klingel oder so, ist egal. Im Grunde ist Helene Fischer DogTV, der DogTV for Professionals. Aber die Idee ist auch supergut, weil irgendwie wenn du einen nervigen Hund hast, der ständig irgendwie durch die Gegend läuft und dir irgendwie dein Essen kackt oder so, sagst du dann setz dich einfach vor den Fernseher, da lernt er noch was, da kannst du auch Werbung platzieren, irgendwie gute Werbepartner, welche Werbepartner, ja wir machen, wir haben zwei Millionen Zuschauer. Frohlich und der Hund dreht dann immer durch, wenn er im Supermarkt das gleiche Logo sieht.
Wie gut, ey. Das ist total gut.
Es ist total clever.
Ich muss kurz meine Nase schnäuzen.
Aber glaubst du auch, man könnte irgendwie Fernsehen für Pflanzen oder sowas machen?
Also wirklich jede Zielgruppe erschliessen.
Also ich glaube, der Menschenmarkt ist zu.
Der Menschenmarkt ist zu, da müssen uns keine Gedanken machen.
Tele 5, lassen wir es.
Vielen Dank. für Pflanzen oder sowas machen? Also wirklich jede Zielgruppe erschliessen. Also ich glaube, der Menschenmarkt ist zu. Der Menschenmarkt ist zu, da müssen uns keine Gedanken mehr machen. Tele fünf, lassen wir es. Was wir versuchen, ist Fernsehen für a Pflanzen, b für Glas. Glas hat sehr spezielle Bedürfnisse. Glas, krass, aber auch pt Flaschen zum Beispiel. Ja, fckw, so ein Kühlschrank hat auch Bedürfnisse, einfach so ein paar Sticker drauf oder sowas. Toast, Toast, den ganzen Tag diese Toast, genau, diese, wie sieht ein Toaster von innen aus oder wie eine Waschmaschine von innen aussieht, finde ich auch geil. Da hat mal jemand, ich meine eine Spülmaschine, weißt du, wo man sich fragt, die Teller macht man dreckig rein und die sind den nächsten Morgen, kommen die sauber raus, wo du denkst, wie geht das eigentlich? Und da hat mal irgendwer eine GoPro da reingestellt, was eine richtig einfache Idee, aber eine sehr geniale Idee ist. Total gute Idee. Und da kommt, hast du es gesehen? Da kommt so ein Arm unten raus, so Science-Fiction-artig, so Star Wars Episode 5 mässig, kommt unten so ein Arm raus und dreht so drum und spritzt alles voll und abgefahren. Ja, total. Vor allem, das war wirklich so ein Aha-Moment für mich, wenn man sich wirklich noch nie Gedanken gemacht hat und so, what? Doch, man hat sich Gedanken gemacht. Da hätte echt alles passieren können. Da hätten irgendwie kleine Roboter-Kreaturen mit Zahnbürsten rausspringen können, die alles sauber wischen. Hätte genauso gut passieren können. Ich sagte, okay, gut, passt, bin ich zufrieden mit von mir aus. Ist DocTV nicht völlig willkürlich, kann man ja nicht einfach so ein Postboten da, das ist doch völlig in Kranzen, die das Bild laufen. Das ist doch voll unerforscht, auch bestimmt. Ja, total, absolut. Aber in einer Waschmaschine ist ja kein Licht, oder? Also er musste auch noch Licht installieren, oder? Es ergibt ja keinen Sinn, das Zeug zu beleuchten. Weiß ich nicht, das weiß ich nicht. Weil ist innen drin Licht auch. Du hast keine Ahnung, wir haben alle keine Ahnung. Waschmaschinen innen drin, Spülmaschinen bleiben. Das ist ein komplett unerforschtes Gebiet. Nee, das ist ein wahnsinnig unerforschtes Gebiet. Das ist ganz schön krass. Aber das können wir bei mehreren Sachen machen, zum Beispiel bei einem Kühlschrank, GoPro in den Kühlschrank. Was passiert da eigentlich so? Ob das Licht wirklich ausgeht? Ja, das ist auch eine Frage, die geklärt werden muss. Oder Mikrowelle, man kann reingucken, aber von innen drinnen haben wir uns auch noch nicht gesehen. Kann man rausgucken? Ja, gute Frage. Kann das Essen einen auch sehen? Kann das Essen rausgucken? Kann die lebende Katze, die man, dem man die letzten Minuten leichter machen will, einen sehen, wenn man die Mikrowelle packt? Food TV, Fernsehen für Essen. Fernsehen für Essen. Abgefahren. Es ist, das Fernibt es ein Dog-TV-YouTube-Channel? Ich glaube nicht. Man muss es weiterdenken. Das Fernsehen ist fortschrittlicher. Da sollte man hin. Wir sollten Telefon. Genau. Wir können Fernsehen nicht weitermachen, so wie es bis jetzt war. Wir brauchen eine komplette revolutionäre Idee, die alles auf den Kopf stellt. Ja. Falschrum. Oder irgendwie so ein Fernseher, der auch noch vibriert. Zusatzfunktion. Ja, oder nur Ton, nur Ton einfach. Nur Ton, finde ich gut. Nur Ton und Geruch. Und sehr billiges Stock-Footage. Stock-Footage. Was nicht passt, aber auch sehr psychedelisch ist. Stimmt, wir hatten ja auch mal die Idee, Audio-Stock-Footage zu produzieren und zu verkaufen, falls das mit dem Fernsehen nichts wird. Wir sind offen für alles. Was mir dazu einfällt, wir haben im Moment wieder die Lokalradios in NRW, die machen zu, immer im Neujahr, das geheimnisvolle Geräusch. Ja. Kennst du das? Ja, ja. Wurde einfach, Achtung, jetzt, das geheimnisvolle Geräusch, pst! Was war es? Kohlerdose, die du aufmachst? Ja, alles, kann alles sein. Und es ist auch völlig egal, welche Flasche man auskommt, einfach alles gleich. Ja, und am Ende ist es dann irgendwas extrem Spezielles. Ja, am Ende ist es irgendwie, ich mache gerade eine Wolwig-Flasche auf. Mit der linken Hand. Mit der Zunge. So was ist es dann. Aber vor allem, was machen die, also das ist ja auch wirklich sehr einfach produzierte Unterhaltung, ne? Also das
ist ja wirklich so einfach. Du nimmst einfach zwei Dinge
zur Reaktion, klappst die einfach vor dem Mikrofon
zusammen und die Leute raten sich den Kopf ab.
Das ist doch wirklich genial.
Das ist ganz schön scheiße, weil auch
alle, weil alle anrufen einfach.
Und ich glaube, die ganze Welt ruft da an,
weil da keine Chance zu gewinnen.
Ein Gewinnspiel fände ich aber gar keine so schlechte Idee.
Vielleicht macht man Fernsehen, in dem es nur
Gewinnspiele gibt, wo man dann anrufen muss, wo gewisse
Vielen Dank. Und ich glaube, die ganze Welt ruft da an, da war keine Chance zu gewinnen. Ein Gewinnspiel fände ich aber gar keine so schlechte Idee. Vielleicht macht man Fernsehen, in dem es nur Gewinnspiele gibt, wo man dann anrufen muss, wo gewisse Rätsel präsentiert werden und die Zuschauer müssen anrufen. Da war uns 9 Live, naja, ein bisschen vielleicht vorweggenommen. Vielleicht sollten wir Rätsel, hast du das gesehen, wo die irgendwann mal, man sieht ja nie, wie die dann die Lösung präsentieren. Das sind ja auch so, dass sie ein bisschen die Lösungen präsentiert bekommen von neuen Live, so ein bisschen so wie in eine Spülmaschine reingucken. Genau, so das Bernsteinzimmer finden. Das hat noch nie jemand erlebt. Und das war wirklich so, dass es keine Lösung gab. Also es waren keine Lösungen. Was war das denn nochmal? Das ist natürlich jetzt blöd, dass mir das nicht einfällt. Das ist natürlich jetzt wahnsinnig antiklimaktisch. Was ich weiss, ist, dass die Lösung einfach falsch ist. Ja, genau. Also da stand dann irgendwie, Jürgen war gestern im Supermarkt und hat es ... gekauft. So, und dann rufen Leute an, irgendwie, keine Ahnung, Schnitzel, Sellerie oder was auch immer, nee, nee, alles falsch, ja, Schokoküsse, nein, falsch. Und die Lösung war tatsächlich, Jürgen hat gestern im Supermarkt Schokokuss gekauft. Es war grammatikalisch einfach falsch. Ne, nur ein leicht verarsch die Leute, das stimmt. Es hat jemand angerufen und Schokoküsse gesagt, wie es grammatikalisch richtig gewesen wäre. Ne, falsch, wie kommst du da rauf? Also das ist auch so lame, einfach zu sagen, die Lösung ist halt einfach falsch. Das ist auch so grossartig. Aber sag mal, gab es nicht früher bei Sat.1 diesen Sat.1-Spaßball, den man durch so ein Labyrinth manövrieren musste, wo man am Telefon dann gesagt hat, links, links, rechts. Aber sehe ich das richtig? Das ist der Anrufer, anruft Herbert, 60 Fernfahrer aus Bottrop und in der Redaktion sitzt ein gelangweilter Praktikant, der darauf hört, was er sagt und immer auf den Knopf drückt, links, links, rechts, rechts. Was ist ist, wenn der Praktikanten Fehler macht und dann irgendwie gegen Hindernis fährt oder so? Das kam bestimmt mal vor, hundertprozentig kam das mal vor. Aber das ist auch so ein Remunizier, als die Idee ich in der Redaktion hatte, Moment, dann sagt der links und Karl, du setzt dich dann in den Controller und drückst nach links und dann kann der Zuschauer dann steuern indirekt, das ist ja total gut. Vor allem wenn der Zuschauer irgendwie was gemacht hätte, womit der Praktikant nicht recht hätte, wäre auch irgendwie geil. Wenn du nicht nach links sagt, sondern plötzlich rückwärts oder so oder oben. Oder springen oder schossen. Der Ball wird jetzt zu einem kleinen Hund. Du denkst noch als DocTV-Redakteur, das gefällt mir. Ja, ich bin gerade noch voll DocTV. Ja, aber vor allem, weil man dieses Spiel auch eigentlich als Anrufer immer nur deswegen verloren hat, weil der Praktikant nicht schnell genug reagiert hat. Es ist keine Herausforderung, links, rechts zu sagen, aber der Praktikant war einfach zu langsam. Es ist wirklich keine Herausforderung. Nein, überhaupt nicht. Lass uns nochmal zu DogTV gehen, ganz kurz, ich komme davon nicht los. Nee, aber es gibt ja auch so Fernseher, die dann zum Beispiel einen Kaminofen zeigen, weil es ja ja schön ist, weil man gerne einen Kaminofen hat. Das wäre ja nicht geil, wenn man einen Sender hätte, der nur den Kaminofen den ganzen Tag zeigen würde. Ja, finde ich gut. Ich glaube, das machen sogar Sender irgendwie in der Nacht, dass sie dann nur noch einen Kamin zeigen. Es gibt auch, ich glaube, wie heißt es nochmal, BahnTV. Gehst du BahnTV? Oh ja, natürlich. Die schönsten Bahnstrecken Deutschlands. Die schönsten Bahnstrecken NRW ist ja klar. Das ist, Das ist glaube ich die einzige Sendung, die immer läuft bei die schönsten Bahnstrecken Deutschlands. Aber es gibt auch irgendwie so in einem Auto, dass man durch eine Stadt fährt in der Nacht. Das gibt es auch. Dass sie einfach eine Kamera in ein Auto hängen und dann einfach durch die Gegend fahren. Aber bei BahnTV ist sehr, sehr enthüllend, weil es gibt keine schönen Bahnstrecken. Nein, gibt es nicht, auch wenn sie das behaupten, sie sind nicht schön. Sie sind nicht schön, sie sind einfach nicht schön. Ihr könnt uns nicht täuschen. Ich bin Stefan Titzel, habe eine Sechst riskiert dafür, dass ich schöne Buchstaben schreibe. Ihr könnt mich nicht täuschen, Ästhetik ist mein Steckenpferd. Ist wirklich so. Kleine Buchstaben sind, finde ich auch immer noch schöner eigentlich. Ja, ist ja auch so im Design oder so. Absolut. Wenn man jetzt, jetzt bin ich mittlerweile 20 Jahre alt und ich kann es klein schreiben alles und es ist mir scheissegal. I don't give a shit, weil es juckt auch keinen mehr, ob ich jetzt was Grohes schreibe. Ja, du brauchst das Verbot, damit du Spaß daran hast, zu sprechen. Genau, ich bin Punk, ich brauche die Verbote, um dann zu eskalieren. Ja, gut. Yeah, würde ich jetzt nicht sagen. Tele 5. Tele 5. Hast du nicht eine Formatidee, irgendwas, was wir machen können, wo man wirklich sagt, also eine Formatidee ist auch die Frage, ob es überhaupt noch neue Formate gibt oder ob einfach schon alles gemacht wurde und alles nur noch irgendwie. Muss man, das ist die alte Frage, muss man das Rad neu erfinden? Ich sage ja. Rat, Rat TV. Also um diese Frage einfach einmal zu beantworten, sage ich ja, tatsächlich muss man. Auch eine gute Idee, unbegründet irgendwas sagen. Ja, wir müssen das Rad neu erfinden. Aber zu der Idee vom Anfang,
brainstorm und nicht zu Ende gedacht.
So was einfach, ich finde auch die Idee,
eine Sendung so zu nennen, brainstorm und nicht zu Ende gedacht.
Und dann einfach irgendwie so einen Tag lang einen Hund zu zeigen, mit einer GoPro
auf dem Rücken oder so, ist geil.
Nervt nach zwei Minuten, aber man muss es einfach durchziehen.
Man kann ja wegschalten.
Das ist ja das Gute am Fernsehen. Ich meine, das ist ein bisschen, ist nicht sehr gut wirtschaftlich gedacht, aber das ist ja die Idee des Fernsehens. Man kann umschalten. Ja, dass man auch zum Beispiel irgendwie in einem Stadion wie so eine Band ihre Bühne aufbaut. Einfach eine GoPro irgendwie ins Stadion klemmen und dann einfach acht Stunden lang zeigen, wie da Leute irgendwie Sachen zusammenschweissen. Super interessant. Oder eine GoPro aus Sicht des Fernsehers zeigen, so TV-TV quasi, und man sieht Leute, wie sie Fernsehen gucken. Das ist geil, man sieht live andere Zuschauer und sie sehen dich. Das dachte ich auch immer. Als Kind denkt man ja immer, dass Leute, die man sieht, die auch sehen. Also habe ich mich vom Fernsehen, ich habe immer geschämt, wenn ich mich morgens mit meinen Bett-Sachen, mit meinem Pyjama als Kind vom Fernseher gesetzt habe, dachte ich immer, ach scheiße, der vom Tigeranglop sieht mich jetzt so. Das will doch keiner, das will er nicht, das will ich nicht. Komm, wir ziehen es durch. Ich bin auch zuvor, was anzusehen, wir ziehen es durch. Das dachte ich mir immer. Ich wollte mich immer schick machen für die Leute, die ich im Fernsehen sehe, aber natürlich, jetzt mittlerweile weiss ich, sie sehen einen nicht ganz. Nicht immer, ja. Sie switchen so zwischen den verschiedenen Durchzuschauen durch. Das wäre doch geil, mal so Fernsehdeutschland zu zeigen. Leute, die eine GfK-Box haben, die kann man auch so eine GoPro hinstellen. Und das Ganze wird dann im Live-Studio übertragen. Genau. Du stellst dann zwei Kameras und zwei Fernseher ins Studio. Genau. dann können die Leute das Publikum sehen, das Publikum sieht dich.
Es ist transparent, es ist pure Transparenz.
Das ist eigentlich ganz gut. Anstatt Dinge anzuschauen, wirst du angeschaut vom Fernseher. Das wäre mal eine echte Revolution.
Man sieht sich selber. Das ist wie FaceTime aus Versehen zu aktivieren.
Ja genau, man sieht sich selber.
FaceTime aus Versehen zu aktivieren kann einem ganz einfach von.
Das ist das Schlimmste der Welt. Oder wenn du irgendwie die Kamera umdrehst oder sowas und dich dann selber siehst, das ist der schlimmste Moment. Oh, das ist das Schlimmste. Naja. Wir sind schon wieder ein bisschen im Luke-Roggen-Mockridge-Niveau, tut mir leid, aber so diese Alltagsobservational-Comedy so, ey, soll ich es auch schon mal per sich auf dem Böger steigen? Observational-Comedy ist grandios. Und da hat Luke-Mockridge glaube ich nicht. Ich habe auch, das ist auch immer alles auf die, hast du irgendwie so ein Faible, hast du irgendwie mal ein Programm von ihm gesehen, dass du denkst, dass du alles auf ihn beziehst immer? Ist Luke Mockridge dein persönliches Dog-TV? Ja, es ist tatsächlich schon. Und der kriegt jetzt auch eine eigene Fernsehsendung und so. Echt jetzt? Ich sage nicht, ja, ja, auf ProSieben oder SatEye ist irgendwie so ein Shit. Ja, der kriegt seine Eier so wie Kajanas Woche, kriegt er Luke Mockridge's eine Sendung. Und ich sage nicht, dass ich die jetzt mehr verdienen würde als Luke Mockridge, das sage ich nicht. Ich sage nur, dass der Typ nichts drauf hat. Dass der Typ, also ich weiß nicht, sollen wir jetzt komplett gegen Luke Mockridge ranten von mir aus. Wir haben uns schon Feinde gemacht, James Franco als Feind gemacht, deswegen Luke Mockridge. Luke Mockridge hat mit Annemarie Warncross, beziehungsweise Annemarie Carpendale mittlerweile, für Fiat oder so, Fiat oder Ford seine Werbung gemacht, wo Annemarie Carpendale immer mit ihrem Fiat zu verschiedenen Leuten hinfährt und ihn interviewt in so sechsminütigen Videos. Und also wirklich, wenn ich eine Parodie schreiben müsste auf diese Situation, ja, du bist Luke Mockridge und du weisst, gleich kommt Ann-Marie Carpendale, dich besuchen in deinem Night-Wash-Wasch-Salon. Wie erwartest du sie? Als Gag, um wirklich als komödiantische Person, als unsympathischer, eingebildeter Typ vielleicht so eine als Figur darzusetzen würde. Ich würde verliebt träumend mit meiner Gitarre auf dem Schoss ein Lied anstimmend dort sitzen und in die Ferne schauen und sinnieren. Als Gag. Und der hat das gemacht nicht als Gag. Genauso sass er da. Annemarie Karpendel kam rein, während er gerade mit seiner scheiss Gitarre da saß, auf seiner fucking Waschmaschine, sass er mit der Gitarre und oh hey Annemarie, ich hab gar nicht gesehen, dass du reingekommen bist. Weißt du, das ist offensichtlich Gag. Sicher, dass das ernst gemeint war? Ja, das ist hundertprozentig ernst gemeint. Ich kann es dir ja nachzeigen, das ist einhundertprozentig ernst gemeint. Gib doch mal die URL durch. Du und hin, wir haben 51 Minuten, wir haben uns nicht mehr zu sagen. Hau jetzt die URL raus. Okay, warte, mach doch jetzt mal. Langsam und deutlich. Genau, möglichst lange URL. Warte mal, ganz kurz, damit ich das kurz finde. Ich würde mich überbrücken mit dem Scheiss,
das kann ich eigentlich immer.
Aber ich finde, diese Formen haben wir
moderativ ganz gut über die Runden
gebracht. Was soll ich sagen? Das nächste Lied kannst du
anmoderieren. Wir hören einfach mal kurz rein.
Sie hören jetzt das beste Lied, was
jemals aufgenommen wurde, Enrique Iglesias
mit Rhythm Divine. Ich finde, wenn man einen Text, den man sagt, genauso ironisch sagen könnte, dann stimmt irgendwas nicht. Wenn man genau sagen könnte, ja, hier haben wir schon die großen Leute gespielt, Mario Barth und so, und es ist ein richtiges Kultding in Köln. Das könnte man eins zu eins so ironisch sagen, und dann stimmt irgendwas nicht. Entweder stimmt nicht, oder man hat die Ironie nicht verstanden. Das kann auch sein, vielleicht ist Luke Mock nicht der grösste Satiriker Deutschlands. Aber man versteht einfach nicht, er ist ein missverstandenes Comedy-Projekt. Er meint das eigentlich lustig, was er sagt. Ich glaube, die halbe Medienwelt ist ein missverstandenes Comedy-Projekt. Luke Mockridge ist ein missverstandenes Comedy-Projekt. Ja, Deutschland hat einfach keinen Humor in der Hinsicht, dass man den Humor einfach nicht versteht. Ja, genau. Das ist eigentlich wahnsinnig lustig, aber man versteht es nicht. Wir verstehen es nicht, ja. Das ist echt, naja, also was du immer so entdeckst, diese Fiat-Fürf, da war noch nie jemand drauf auf der Seite, glaube ich. Nee, glaube ich auch nicht. Vor allem, ich habe das auch im ICE, wollte ich das anschauen, und dieser Player ist total beschissen und lädt irgendwie nicht vor, sondern lädt irgendwie nur die nächste Sekunde vor. Und im ICE hat man immer sehr schlechtes Internet. Deswegen muss ich das immer wieder neu aufrufen. Und echt, ich habe immer das Gefühl, wenn ich im ICE am Laptop arbeite, dass die Person hinter mir konstant auf meinen Bildschirm schaut. Das ist natürlich nicht so, aber ich habe das Gefühl. Und mir war es so unangenehm, diese scheiß Luke-Mockets-Seite. Weil er keine Hose anhat. Wenn er eine Hose anhatte, dann wäre es alles entspannter gewesen. Aber ich habe das immer 20, 30 Mal aufgerufen und nochmal aufgerufen, nochmal Vollbild, okay, lädt, aus, wieder zu und wieder aufgerufen und immer neu und immer wieder und das war echt furchtbar. Und gerade YouTube-Videos, wo irgendwelche Frauen vloggen, ist immer so unangenehm, finde ich, sich das anzuschauen, weil du sitzt da wirklich in einer ICE und starrst einer fremden Frau ins Gesicht einfach zehn Minuten lang und von außen betrachtet sieht das einfach so komisch aus. Und dann der obligatorische Fussel genau auf dem Gesicht. Genau, der obligatorische Fussel auf dem Gesicht. Da musst du mir ja wegwischen, weil du kannst es nicht, weil du bist dann immer so ein Stück weit Monk. Ja, dann feuchtest du noch deine Finger so ein bisschen an. Leckst über den Bildschirm, weil es sonst nicht weggeht. Och mein Gott, mein Gott.
Ja, aber was machen denn die Geschäftsbänder da, die immer auf ihre Laptops starren, mit ihren leeren Blicken und den tief durchtränkten Augen? Und immer irgendwelche Tabellen ausführen. Ich saß auch letztens... Excel-Tabellen, ne? Ja, die Fahrt von Köln nach Berlin sass ich irgendwie vier Stunden lang neben jemandem, der einfach Tabellen gearbeitet hat. Er hat einfach nur Tabellen,, er hat eine Tabelle hoch, Tabelle hoch, Tabelle klein, Tabelle groß, Tabelle links, Tabelle links. Gesumt, wieder zurückgezoomt, wieder ein bisschen gesumt und wieder... Genau, ausgefüllt, wieder gelöscht, wieder ausgefüllt, wieder gelöscht. Ich finde es beeindruckend, wenn Leute im Zug arbeiten können. Ja, total. Und vor allem, man hat ja auch überhaupt keine Ahnung, was andere Leute so arbeiten. Also so ein Random-Typ auf der Strasse, was arbeitet der? Ja, vor allem, wenn man mit den Medien arbeitet und man denkt, man kommt angestrengt nach Hause und ist fertig, ist kaputt von der Arbeit.
Und es gibt Leute da draußen, die arbeiten wirklich, die arbeiten wirklich, die füllen Excel-Tabellen aus und denken dabei nach.
Ja, aber es gibt in Menschen tausende Menschen, die den ganzen Tag vor Excel-Tabellen sitzen und einfach nicht genau weiss, was sie machen. Und die müssen auch ein Pensum schaffen. Die müssen auch fünf Excel-Tabellen pro Tag ausfüllen, komplett, bis zum Ende. Bis sie unten angekommen sind. Einfach ausfüllen, ja. Egal, was ihr reinschreibt, Hauptsache da steht was drin. Ja, genau. Das ist auch eine Arbeit, die will man auch nicht machen, ne? Aber irgendwer muss sie ja machen. Ja. Wir sind am Ende angekommen. Ich finde, wenn es schafft, Luke Mocker in ProSieben zu kommen, schaffen wir es auch in Tele 5. Das hat jetzt heute vielleicht noch nicht ganz so gut geklappt. Die Ideen waren noch ein bisschen ... Die Ideen waren ein bisschen cruel, aber das war Brainstorming, weißt du, das ist immer der erste Schritt. Die Ideen waren nicht vorhanden. Lass uns nächste Woche mal wirklich auf Brainstorming-Programm-Vorschläge gehen, komplett. Lass uns mal diesen Luke-Mockridge-Bashing sei denn, er hat mal wieder ein Video hochgeladen, wo er keine Hose anhat, dann kann man nicht anders als auszurasten. Absolut. Aber genau, lass uns nächste Woche mal irgendwie auf den Brainstorming für Programmideen einfach eingehen, stumpf. Das ist eine gute Idee. Wunderbar. Und wenn ihr natürlich tolle Ideen habt, mit denen wir ins Telefonfernsehen kommen können, dann schreibt sie uns noch auf Facebook oder auf unserer... Leute, ihr fucking Leute, schreibt uns generell mal irgendwas. Ich habe noch nicht einmal gehört, irgendwas zur Sendung gehört. Podcast-UFO.Fail, dort habt ihr genug Kommentarfunktionen, in denen ihr was schreien schreiben könnt. Ist das so? Ich war auf der Seite lange nicht mehr. Ich glaube schon, ansonsten einmal die Facebook-Seite. Neu auf der Seite ist auch ein toller Effekt, ein toller Sound-Effekt, der auf die Seite kommt, ungefragt sich öffnet und das Kache voll macht. Ansonsten auf Facebook das Podcast-UFO, das, nicht nur Podcast-UFO, sondern das Podcast-UFO. Ich bedanke mich ganz recht recht herzlich bei Stefan Titzel für diese wunderschöne halbe Stunde, die wir zusammen genossen haben. Ich bedanke mich bei Florentin Will, aber es hat sich angefühlt wie zwei Stunden. Bis dann. Wir wünschen euch einen schönen Abend, macht's gut und bleibt uns treu.
Ufo, hebt ab!